in the seaside village of Novartis in
the Philippines
Eric hare Emiliano has been behaving
erratically for months people here
believe that his soul is under siege by
none other than the devil himself the
Philippines is home to over 60 million
Catholics for most Filipinos their
concept of evil is based on the
Christian belief in the devil Eric's
mother Elena harami Yano fears for her
son's soul every night she reads the
Bible and prays for him often that's
when the trouble starts tonight a
reading from Scripture triggers
something in Eric his hand shake his
eyes roll back in his head sometimes I'm
afraid Alayna believes evil has
descended upon her son he claims not to
remember what happens during his attacks
by Catholic tradition only priests can
conduct exorcisms but one of manila's
most famous exorcists is a former
Catholic who offers his services for
free he'll see hundreds of patients in a
day they called him ha among convinced
that evil spirits possess her son Elena
seeks help from Kali monk to purge the
spirit The Exorcist must first identify
it
we'll try to find out who's possessing
you okay
he places feathers between Eric's toes
in a belief that they will invoke the
spirit Satan is just one possible source
of the evil in Eric before Filipinos
adopted Christianity they believed in a
whole host of evil spirits to this day
demons evil dwarves and trolls are
blamed for a variety of maladies
but the exorcist suspects that this time
the devil himself is involved first time
this boy I immediately knew this wasn't
an ordinary case of possession I touched
the feet felt the shiver I knew it was a
bad one car among tries to communicate
with the spirit whoever you are I just
want to speak with you I wish you no
harm
to the Exorcist it appears that the
spirit has seized control he demands
answers
why are you in the child go ahead speak
what is the reason this is something you
need from him in a state of possession
eric begins to scribble it's a
disturbing message garbled words about
darkness and the devil for two days just
go to church so that your prayer comes
from your heart two days have passed
Eric and Alayna returned to the Exorcist
taw
among begins again by placing the
feathers between Eric's toes he tries to
contact the spirit does that hurt
nothing
ha Eamon finds nothing wrong he believes
a powerful combination of the earlier
exorcism and Elena's prayers have
vanquished the evil spirit they won't
come back it's over you've gotten
through it Alayna is relieved Eric seems
better but to be sure she seeks further
guidance from her priest father Rik has
performed nine exorcism sanctioned by
the church but he's skeptical whether
Eric was really possessed within minutes
the priest uncovers another possible
reason Eric's father died several months
ago and Eric only heard about it three
months later the attack started around
the same time father Rik suspects Eric
has been suffering from psychological
trauma the priest thinks the exorcism
might have made the attacks worse by
convincing Eric that his spirit was to
blame
but car among still believes he saved
the boy he says the church disapproves
of his work because he's not a priest
what can I say to people let's say this
is taboo that is your opinion
honor and respect I'm only doing this to
help you do it without as long as
thousands of people in Manila continued
to believe in his powers
Kaah Iman will continue to battle evil
spirits free of charge